yeah today's question comes from martin
in california he said i started the
debt-free journey
before i got married my then fiance knew
i was on this journey but never gave me
her true thoughts about it we've been
married four months now
and i still can't get her on board with
paying off debt with budgeting
and being a teammate on this journey i
signed up for fpu but she refuses to
watch the lessons with me
she also does not accept the unity of
marriage
she still continues on about what's hers
as hers and what's mine is mine
i feel like i can't win with money as
long as i'm with her would you recommend
marriage counseling
or is there another way to get her on
board with our debt-free journey
oh man martin you're getting this early
on a marriage
uh yeah this is a hard one i mean my my
first question
i would have so many questions for her
of asking her
not in a you know um
major conflict type way but ask her hey
why ask her the why why does she not
want to do this
what about this makes her uncomfortable
what about this does she not like i mean
going in and asking more of the of the
questions of understanding what really
is preventing her from being on the same
team and if you guys get to a point that
you cannot
get on the same team after you both have
had multiple conversations and again
you're kind of digging into more
uh under the surface then yeah i mean i
think bringing in a third party is
always smart you tried
fpu but if she refuses to watch it she
refuses to watch it
but yeah i mean marriage counseling i
would start having those red
lights are going to start flashing
though martin because money fights and
money problems
they are one of the leading causes of
divorce and the fact that she
is not on the same page with you worries
me a lot and so i would kind of get down
and figure out what
what is she fearful of why is she
choosing not to do this
and then for the betterment of your
marriage yeah i definitely would
recommend marriage counseling
you indeed marriage counseling for sure
no question about it
uh you needed pre-marriage counseling
and you should have discovered all of
this ahead of time
any of you out there listening this is
what you want to avoid
the the data on marriage there's lots of
data
everybody talks about fifty percent of
the marriage assumed in divorce no they
really don't
that includes people who get married at
16 years old after becoming pregnant in
high school
okay well yeah that you're gonna have
struggle with that one
statistically that's a marriage that's
not got a shot
now some people make it thank goodness
but that one's a real tough one okay
and you know listen if you make if your
household income
is over 70 000 a year you have
four-year education your parents are
married
you dated for six months or more
prior to getting married you
uh in less than five years by the way
you um have a religious uh affiliation
you are in agreement on your religious
affiliation
and you have one your percentage chance
of divorce is
very very low it drops down under 10
then but so you know but the problem is
you guys
obviously did not get into in this
particular case
enough pre-marriage counseling you
didn't know each other
because she has something that's driving
this i don't know whether it's fear or
anger but she's obstinate and
man that is an uncomfortable life you
have in your future
living with an obstinate spouse and so
yeah you need marriage counseling um
but this is the reason young people that
you
date for a little while you have a very
intentional
old-fashioned word courting process
where you are
discovering everything about the other
person you're doing pre-marriage
counseling prior to getting married
because it increases your probability of
a successful marriage
and it decreases the pain
that young martin is getting ready to go
through yeah and some of the things that
you know you just listed out are not in
your control as a person you can't
control if your parents have stayed
married or not
you can't control certain things but
what you can control though is to see
the data point of marriage and there's
like the four main reasons why people
get divorced
and the four main causes of fights and
it's what is it
it's money it's sex it's in-laws
and raising kids and that's like the big
points of tension so if those are the
four big red flags
it's actually religion not sex but yeah
oh really
yeah being it doesn't matter so you put
five in there if you want i don't know
lists with different with different
things and sometimes the money thing is
like number five it doesn't make a top
four on stuff i mean like it's
there's a range though of of things that
have conflict with the marriage
so if those are red flags and all of
that raise them up and just say hey
we need i mean all of you dating and
engaged
dig into these areas before you get
married for sure but martin yeah i mean
i would for sure you need
because again this isn't just a money
problem this is the fact that she
doesn't want to play on the same team
and that worries me more than just that
she won't budget or get out of debt with
you there's something even more so
marriage counseling for sure get a good
one and
stick with it yeah i mean uh having
disagreements is one thing in a in a
young marriage like that being
obstinate is another and belligerent and
the the verbage that you're using is
indicating that's where she is
so that's pretty scary stuff